existe outra propriedade interessante da
aa pronobis conhecida pelo nome de
mucilagem é uma substância encontrada em
muitas outras plantas e que é feita de
uma mistura de carboidratos solúveis em
água a mucilagem é produzida pelas
células da planta e fica armazenada
dentro delas e quando a planta é cortada
ou mastigada essa substância é liberada
e forma uma espécie de gosma viscosa e
pegajosa que tem a capacidade de
absorver grandes quantidades de água
formando um gel que pode ajudar a
lubrificar o trato gastrointestinal e
assim regular a digestão Pois é a hora
pronobis é cheia dessa mucilagem e de
fibras então ela dá aquela força na
digestão e melhora o trânsito intestinal
combatendo o intestino preso e até
prevenindo doenças do intestino grosso
do Colon ela ainda pode proteger as
mucosas do nosso trato gastrointestinal
contra irritações e as temidas
inflamações diminuindo assim os sintomas
de doenças como gastrite e colite